hi I'm Jason Biggs I work for Wolfram
research and I am the lead developer for
the chemistry functionality in Wolfram
language and so I talk this talk is
about the the molecule introduced in
version 12 as well as some of the the
enhancements that are planned for 12.1
and beyond
all right my name is Jason Biggs I've
been a chemistry developer at Wolfram
research for the past three years now
and I'm gonna show you this is my third
time giving a talk in here and so this
will hopefully build a little bit on the
previous talks but also show some new
stuff let's see so brief outline right
so I'm gonna briefly talk about what
what has been chemistry in the Wolfram
language up until version 12 I went more
in depth in that last year so so we'll
just kind of try and fly right through
that we'll talk about the molecule which
was introduced in version 12 it's a new
computable data structure will look at
some import/export one of the features
for 12-1 that we're working on is to
update the number of formats that you
can export a molecule from and import a
molecule into a brief preview of some
some post twelve functionality and then
I have a couple of more in-depth
applications which if history is
anything it tells me anything then I'll
be too late to even get to those but
hopefully not because I think they're
interesting and then I would like to to
plug the second talk from the Wolfram
chemistry team that takes place today at
2:30 in the fighting in this in this
very room stepping towards chemistry
mastery about the continuing efforts of
a step by step in chemistry and Wolfram
Alpha all right so let's see from
chemical data two entities and beyond so
starting in version 6
we had chemical data which was a which
is what we like to call curated data
right so we present when you when you
installed Mathematica you would have
there in the layout these files that
that contained all this data that was
curated by by people who work in Wolfram
research from sources such as NIST
pubchem chemspider kaamika labs tracks
and so so the way a chemical data works
that there and there has to be data in
the in the Pacolet it has to have been
curated so you say chemical data I want
propane give me the combustion heat and
so it will return the value because
because we have the value there and so
likewise you can ask for the Vander
Waals constants of ISO nan neol peroxide
and also we have thermodynamic data
which as it allows a little bit of
computation so we have entities in
thermodynamic data you can you can ask
about the molar isobaric heat capacity
and provide a temperature and it and I
use it and it can compute that so that
was introduced in version 6 this was
extended to 2 included not just chemical
entities there were there were elements
there were minerals there were cities
and so so a new framework was needed to
to deal with arbitrary types of entities
and properties about them and that's
where entity value comes in so so for
for entity value you have these things
which you've seen in other talks which
we call we call them yellow boxes this
is this is a random chemical and this is
the same it draws them the same
knowledge base the same information
bases chemical data but but it's more
easily updatable and it's a more
cohesive framework so in an entity value
of classes of entities fret for instance
greenhouse gases gives you a list of all
the chemicals that have been curated
into the to the category of greenhouse
gases you've got lots of properties and
you've got an Access or function entity
value which allows you to to take
entities and properties and get the the
information in a nice and computable
presentable form so we've also got
service connections so for things
outside of the the knowledge base of
things in other external databases like
PubMed so you can create a service
connection to pubchem and this returns a
service object you can then query that
give it give it some type of identifier
to represent a chemical in this case
chlorine dye
outside and you can ask for the compound
description and it returns this nice
data set of all the information
available on pubchem likewise we
introduced the the Wolfram data
repository which allows not just the
curators at Wolfram research but anyone
to submit their own to curated data and
so for example these are three external
data sets that were turned into entity
stores and so this is a way to extend
the knowledge base so this is the GD
benign database and if I click on this
it'll take me to the to an external web
page that gives me information about
that data set but if I if I call
resource data GD benign database then it
gives me an entity store and I can
access it using the very same framework
that I just described the entity value
so there are properties and entities and
you can you can query for the values and
present them all in a nice data set in
the same way and there there are more of
these data sets and then there's also
Wolfram Alpha right you can access it on
the web or within your notebook you can
ask natural language queries like how
many carbon atoms and 5.4 six kilograms
of propane and you can ask for the pH of
2 molar acetic acid likewise you can see
likewise you can look at the step by
step to figure out the percent yield for
a given chemical reaction but I'm not
going to talk too much about the step by
steps because that's that's for the talk
today at 2:30 so with version 12 we have
the molecule a molecule allows you to
create an object that represents a
chemical species and so so the the
molecule it doesn't rely on the external
database it doesn't rely on a connection
to two entity value it it sits in your
notebook and it's created on the fly
when you
a molecule of water it creates this
molecule you it's it's composed of atoms
and bonds so you can get its atom list
or its bond list or actually you can
just look at it just like any other
Wolfram language expression you can ask
for its input form and you see it's a
molecule it has the head molecule a list
of atoms a list of bonds and so you can
you can have more complicated ones
molecule no I mean I always pull this
one out as an example of a molecule that
has stereochemistry
so there's L when I say l-alanine it
describes the 3d arrangement of the
atoms it tells you a little bit about
about the stereochemistry of that
molecule so for the input form and so
again we have a list of atoms a list of
bonds and some stereochemistry elements
that tells me that if I look at the the
atom represented by number two in this
atom list that the the ligands around it
the other atoms that are attached to it
when listed in this particular order go
counterclockwise such things are
actually very important in chemistry and
so finding a way to to represent those
computationally as important so you can
ask for molecule properties and this in
much the same way that you can ask for
properties of entities except for in
this case they're computed on the fly
they're not stored before you ask for
them so you can ask for the molecular
mass the point group you can make
changes to the molecule if you take your
your molecule and you can set the mass
number and so in this case we took water
and we turned it into D 2 or heavy water
yeah
Yeah right so so so if you don't supply
coordinates then then we need to create
coordinates and so there's a there's a
nice algorithm built-in that will that
we'll use
so so I can talk more about the
algorithm that generates those
coordinates but so it generates
coordinates and then we use a force
field to try and minimize them and then
we can return the the point group yeah
absolutely and you can bring in your
coordinates from an XYZ or an SD file
let's see so there's there's ways to
visualize the molecule so so I can
create a molecule and I can make a 2d
and 3d plots of it if I want to show the
hydrogen's where if I want to hide them
typically so can everybody see I put the
this up to 150% okay I mean so I mean
you might not see the little HS or
whatnot but the when when a chemist
makes a drawing like this it's
understood that even though there's no
see here that that's a carbon and when
and it's understood that even though
there is no hydrogen listed right here
that because that carbon has a double
bond and a single bond in order for it
to be a neutral molecule there as if
there is a missing hydrogen and so we in
order to draw less cluttered diagrams we
will typically omit those and so but you
can control that via the plot theme or
via the include hydrogen's option which
I'll get to it on done so likewise the
there there's a molecule plot 3d with
its own plot themes you can special
ball-and-stick you can omit the balls
for the atoms altogether or just use
those represent the atoms as spheres
with the van der Waals radius you can
highlight in atoms so if I say I want a
molecule plot of M which is defined
above and I want to highlight atom 9 and
I want to highlight this particular bond
and then I want to highlight all oxygen
atoms then I can do that and the the
colors are chosen automatically if I
wanted to provide my own color then I
could wrap these in style and provide a
color so this this I'm always impressed
by this so I always try and throw this
into the into this and to the the talks
so in order for chemical names can be
rather long and descriptive so the whole
point of an eye you pack name is to
systematically tell you just using text
what the 3d structure of this molecule
is going to be so in this case so the
rules for the for these are dictated by
the the blue book and the red book
imagine I had a little bit of dynamic
there so so they they popped out but
okay so so for a name like this we have
2 3 3 try chloro probe 2 you know ik
acid so what that means is with the base
we have an you know ik acid or let's see
you know enol or Cassidy and then 2 3 3
try chloro and so so it that this is all
of that structure is encoded in the name
and when I say molecule of this name
that is decoded and turned into what's
called a smile string and from that
smile string we build the chemical graph
likewise 1 3 3 try meth oxy propylene so
probe 1 in alright and then you've got
try methoxy and the 1 3 3 says where
those those three methyl groups live and
likewise we can we can do a big name
like this and I'm not going to walk you
through that one but I mean that's the
cool thing right so so you've got
companies that have been around for a
hundred years like Chemical Abstracts
service is whose whole job is to take
molecules that chemists make in the lab
and find out what the proper name for it
is and there that is I mean there's
science to that but that is definitely
an art
but then going once they've done that
work of making the IU pack name coming
back out to the structure well that can
be done algorithmically and so I show
this on the very last slide but this is
done via the option of library I mean
it's a it's phenomenal library and it's
included it's it's not that when I when
we when we do this it doesn't make any
call to the knowledgebase I could have
turned off the internet and it will just
do it using the the what's included in
the layout no so I mean that that is a
much harder problem and to do that
algorithmically I I'm aware of one of
one commercial solution that does that
but yeah it's a harder problem let's see
so I mentioned properties so once we
create a molecule we can we can get the
molar mass on the fly there are a whole
host of properties so so in order to
discover them the autocomplete is great
so here I've got molecule value and then
C so these don't scale as well with the
one hundred and fifty percent but if I
just scroll through this I can I can see
all the different properties that can be
computed right I can get the bridgehead
atom count for example which would be
the the number of atoms that that bridge
a ring and so if we want if you want to
look at all of those properties you can
create you they're grouped into
different types of properties right so
general properties geometric properties
which includes the the coulomb matrix
inter atomic distance principal axes
yeah and so they're they're easily
discoverable in that way and yeah so i
think that's about all for that one
right so molecule patterns so once you
have a molecule so you might want to to
look inside that molecule to see does
this does this molecule have a carbon
atom does this molecule have any any cat
does it have anything with a ring and so
we've got a an expressive language for
that for describing patterns right so
here's here's a list of patterns one
that represents an oxygen one that
represents any atom with a formal charge
greater than zero and so I can take
those and I can make a an association
where I give a label to the pattern and
I can put just put that directly in a
molecule plot and it'll highlight and
show me the oxygen atoms the cations so
here what do I have a TNT right and so
yeah it works very quickly you can do
the same thing with bonds right so in
this case this is a pattern for a
nitrogen nitrogen bond a pattern for any
type of a halogen bond and then likewise
I can just give those two molecule plot
and find the the amount of the pattern
inside the molecule if I want a bigger
pattern more than just a single bond or
a single atom I we have a data structure
called the molecule pattern which is
like a molecule it's got a list of atoms
which can be patterns right so they have
this is one with a heavy atom
coordination number greater than two so
that means an oxygen atom that's bonded
to two other atoms that are not hydrogen
and so then and so that here highlighted
in yellow
so this is our carbonic ester okay so
now now we come to import/export right
so so we've got various formats that
have been of around in the system for
quite some time at the for chemical date
when chemical data came out we were able
to to import things like XYZ files or
PDB files and create graphics out of
them well now when we import them we can
create a molecule right so with a SD
file this is a this is one of the more
widely used formats around now right so
it allows you to store two
or 3d coordinates and an arbitrary set
of properties and new in version 12v we
have much faster access right so I have
this particular SD file that I
downloaded seems to be some some patent
data patent mining is a big area in CHEM
informatics at the moment and so you'll
find these SD files and this one has two
hundred and seventy-five thousand
molecules right and so how long does it
take - it takes just let's see last time
I ran this it only took five seconds to
figure out that there were there were
two hundred and seventy-five thousand
molecules in it and if I want to I can
access those without reading the whole
thing in
so before version 12 if I wanted to have
just the two hundred thousandth mount
molecule it would read in all two
hundred seventy-five thousand and then
just pull out the two hundred thousandth
and so in this case it doesn't do that
here what I'm asking for I'm saying give
me the first through the two hundred
thousandth in steps of five thousand and
when I ran that before it took five
seconds and then at the end we had yeah
we have forty molecules and so that's a
big improvement XYZ files now this is a
this is a tricky problem right so so
when I taken a molecule and I export it
as an X Y Z so let's let's start with
this let's make that and then let's an
export that as an X Y Z string so all
you have in an XYZ file is the list of
atoms
and the list of coordinates you have no
bond information and so the problem then
if for importing it is what we call
connecting the dots if we want to import
it we have to know that there were bonds
between which atoms and we had more than
that we'd like to know what kinds of
bonds they are and so that's gotten a
lot better that will get a lot better in
twelve point one and twelve there were
some cases where you would import
something from an XYZ file and it would
have bonds listed as undefined so we're
we're improving that in twelve one so in
this case I exported
an XYZ and then I import that same thing
back to a molecule and it turns out to
be the same molecule so we've already we
will always had a CIF importing so if
you import a CIF file you get this kind
of information this is generally useful
for solid state type of chemistry which
is not my forte
but now you should be able to import
that as a molecule in which case you
take take the fractional coordinates
provided in the file and convert them to
a cartesian coordinate and you also get
two meta information about the unit cell
likewise we're gonna have import and
export for Hyper can format which I
don't think it's all that well what that
widely used so let's not talk about that
yeah so I've heard people ask about that
right and so that so please please come
on Wednesday like so I'm having a one of
the round tables at the lunch and so
essentially I don't know very much about
solid-state chemistry and so I would I
could imagine there being a data
structure that is a units that has the
head unit cell and I could imagine
plotting it right and just saying how
many unit cells you would like in the
plot but other than that I don't fully
know what people would want to do with
it more towards what a where where I
come
my background is this the formatted
checkpoint file right so this is
produced by the Gaussian software so so
if you've run some calculations and you
end up with a formatted checkpoint file
you can now import it it contains a 3d
coordinates but then it also has a lot
of other meta information about the
orbitals and the energies and then the
more flashy of the new formats would be
the cube file
right so this is a volumetric daddy data
right so if I look at the first few
lines on one of these files it tells me
it tells me about a grid that the
Barwick that that it's giving me it
tells me basically it gives me the XYZ
coordinates and and the atomic numbers
and masses for all the atoms and then it
just lists number after number and and
it goes on and on and on and essentially
what that is is it's giving me all the
value of the electronic wave function or
the electronic density on each of these
grid points and so then the goal is when
you import it you'll get back a molecule
if you look at its meta information then
it's going to have this volumetric data
right so it'll have it'll have all of
the that data from the from the cube but
then it'll also tell you the range which
you could then plug into a list contour
plot 3d or you could just import the the
graphics 3d element right and so you
could get these nice nice plots and
here's one that shows not a wave
function but the electronic density so
when that says two minutes left what
does it mean it really means it okay
okay so just a few of these toy little
functions that I've been working on here
right so we've got our resonance
structures what this means is when you
look at ozone here it has a double bond
on one of these and a single bond on the
other what that's just because when we
describe these as a chemical graph as a
molecule object we have to assign a bond
order to everyone but in reality it's
some combination of the two so resonance
structure list will uh will expand that
out so likewise for benzene right it's
not just this is the double bond this is
a double bond this is a double bond but
it's it's in resonance there are these
two structures that occur at the same
time we've got tautomers which are
different than than resonance structures
tautomers are actually distinct species
but they can readily interconvert
amongst each other in different
environments so in this case you've got
isocyanate acid this hydrogen
move from this oxygen all the way to the
other nitrogen and we call them a mobile
hydrogen likewise
for a phosphonic acid right you can have
this the hydrogen move from from one of
the the oxygens onto the phosphorus
which is why this is a diprotic acid and
not a triprotic acid which you might
think it would be and then if you take
something like this molecule which I
don't have its name then we can find 375
tautomers and like I said I'm going to
have to skip over the the applications
but I do want to touch on molecule
recognize right so you have this image
and it's got a head of image and we can
convert that directly into a molecule by
using optical character recognition
hahaha
likewise here right so I can do molecule
we recognize of this and it becomes this
molecule and I'm just going to come on
over to the last slide and thank the the
other members of the chemistry team it's
not yeah this is definitely a team
effort and likewise as we rely heavily
on some open source packages yeah
you